erstmal vielen herzlichen Dank für die
Einladung es freut mich wirklich sehr
jetzt heute hier ein bisschen über die
Zeit bzw die Chronobiologie sprechen zu
dürfen als Teil des Münchner Dozierenden
Netzwerks also auch mein erstes Mal hier
deswegen freue ich mich ganz besonders
und es ist auch sehr schön finde ich
dass die TU als Wahrzeichen einen
Uhrenturm hat tatsächlich das hilft mir
immer ganz gut schönen mein Thema
einzusteigen da ich mich ja eben mit
Chronobiologie beschäftige genau also es
soll heute über Eulen und Lärchen gehen
die grüne Biologie unsere unseren Alltag
unseren Hochschulalltag beeinflusst und
dazu möchte ich eigentlich drei Themen
abfangen jetzt in den nächsten Gruppen
halben Stunde einmal was ist denn die
Uhren wie tickt sie dann welchen welche
die Ursache oder wie sieht denn aus dem
Schlafmangel vor allem bei Teenagerinnen
und jungen Erwachsenen und das welche
Rolle hat es dann letztendlich für
unsere Lehre für unsere Hochschullehre
aber ganz viel auch eigentlich in der
Sekundarstufe denn da habe ich mich
tatsächlich damit beschäftigt während
meiner Doktorarbeit was ich aber auch so
ein bisschen übersetzen lässt in die in
die junge erwachsenenzeit also sprich in
der Universität
genau
mein Take Away von vornherein also wenn
es dieses eins mitnehmen von diesen
Vortrag dann vielleicht sowas wie
schlafen und schlafen lassen das hat
jetzt vielleicht erstmal nichts mehr
Zeit zu tun aber ich hoffe ich kann sie
dann überzeugen dass es doch ein
bisschen was eine Zeit zu tun hat und so
ganz nach dem Motto leben und leben
lassen habe ich das Gefühl könnten wir
in unserer Gesellschaft auch ein
bisschen mehr von schlafen und schlafen
lassen gebrauchen und deswegen ist es
einfach mein take away
schauen wir mal ob ich sie überzeugen
kann gut was ist Chronobiologie also das
ganze stammt von Coronas Zeit und ähm
ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen anders
als Sie erwarten Sie erwarten jetzt
vielleicht ja wie kann der Mensch Zeit
messen oder wie
wie kann er Zeit
vorhersehen also kann er sowas wie
annehmen wie wie lange dauert eine halbe
Stunde und so weiter das ist tatsächlich
nicht ganz das was die Chronobiologie
beschreibt sondern es geht bei der
kronobiologie eigentlich umso interne
ähm des Körpers und die im Endeffekt
dadurch vermutlich entstanden sind dass
sich die Erde einfach dreht die gewisse
Konstellation im Sonnensystem einfach
vorher schon irgendwie somit sondern 24
Stunden Rhythmus auf der Erdkugel haben
Licht dunkelwechsel und im Endeffekt wir
uns da dran angepasst haben als Menschen
als Tiere
es gibt so verschiedene Grundrhythmen
die wir in der Chronobiologie
beschreiben das sind immer circa
Rhythmen weil sie eben biologisch
bedingt nicht exakt auf die 100.000
Sekunde richtig ticken sozusagen sondern
ungefähr ein Gewissen Rhythmus
beschreiben und da gibt es eben sagen
also so jahreszeitliche
rhythmens also eher mohnzeiten
orientiert sich der Mensch jetzt eher
weniger dran gibt es aber ganz viele
hantiereich dann gibt es auch circa
Teile wird dann die noch weniger für den
Menschen relevant sind eher wenn jetzt
z.B fischen gehen würde aber das sind
keine internen Rhythmen des Menschen
sondern eher der Tiere die sich daran
angepasst haben und dann gibt's noch die
anderen
den wir sehr sehr gut erforscht haben
der bei Menschen sehr gut untersucht ist
einfach weil natürlich die Perioden
darauf und 24 Stunden deutlich geringer
ist und somit einfach hat so untersuchen
als jetzt jahreszeitliche beispielsweise
genau welche Vorteile hat denn jetzt
eigentlich wenn man Rhythmus überhaupt
haben also wieso brauche ich einen
rücken muss also das ist natürlich so
nur eine gewisse Hypothese
aber es ist natürlich so man kann sich
schon überlegen wenn jetzt ein
Organismus einen gewissen Rhythmus hat
und nicht einfach völlig arrhythmisch
lebt dann kann ein gewisse Veränderungen
in der Natur antizipieren und somit kann
der Organismus der Mensch Lebewesen sich
natürlich auch an ein gewisses
verändertes Nahrungsangebot anpassen das
ist sowohl über den Jahresverlauf als
auch täglich zum Beispiel er kann auch
räumliche zeitliche und soziale Nischen
nutzen die ganz wichtig auch fürs
Überleben sein könnten und er kann
natürlich gewisse Ruhe und
Aktivitätsphasen ja wichtig sind für die
Physiologie eben verteilen über 24
Stunden und so anpassen dass sie am
besten funktionieren das ist so ein
bisschen die Theorie dahinter
genau also jetzt sprechen ich
hauptsächlich in meinem Vortrag von
caillen oder nicht nur hauptsächlich
spreche eigentlich nur von Jahren also
sprich diese 24 Stunden und es bedeutet
im Endeffekt dass jeder Organismus und
tatsächlich vermutlich jede Zelle sogar
im Körper
diese innere Uhr hat mit einer Periode
also sprich einer Länge von ca 24
Stunden
das heißt es zirkuliert quasi so hoch
und runter mit einer Dauer von ungefähr
24 Stunden und das heißt es gibt einfach
Phasen wo wir am besten verdauen können
es gibt Phasen wo wir am besten
sportliche Leistungen erbringen können
es gibt Phasen wo wir kognitiv am besten
und am leistungsfähigsten sind und es
gibt Phasen wo wir auch gut laufen
können und bekommt da kommt eben jetzt
auch der Schlaf ein bisschen ins Spiel
genau und jetzt hier noch mal ein
bisschen ne schematische Darstellung wie
das Ganze dann abläuft
und sie hatten wir in der Einleitung
erwähnlich besprechen ich beschäftige
mich auch mit lichtexpositionen jetzt
verstehen sie vielleicht dann gleich
warum das irgendwie überhaupt eine Rolle
spielt und zwar ist es so dass wir eben
erstmal so einen Input von außen
brauchen in Form von Licht das nennt man
dann Zeitgeber und das tatsächlich auch
ein Wort das Eingang in die Fachsprache
gefunden hat also auch im englischen
spricht man von Zeitgeber und das kann
also das hauptsächlich Sonnenlicht kann
auch so ein bisschen
also keine grundsätzlich Licht sein also
mutig aber das ist eigentlich nicht so
relevant weil es zu schwach ist aber
hauptsächlich ist es die Sonne die uns
diese Zeit vorgibt
was dann wiederum einen gewissen
genetischen Oszillator triggert
das ist quasi dann schematisch
letztendlich was wir als
rechnen und dann diese innere Uhr dieser
Taktgeber sagt dann dafür dass wir im
Körper selbst also auf allen möglichen
Ebenen ein Gewissen Output haben der
sich in der Rhythmik äußert also das
kann in der Biochemie sein Physiologie
Verhalten Kognition und so weiter und
für diese Beschreibung des genetischen
Oszillators haben 2017 auch drei Herren
hier Jeffrey Hall Michael und Michael
young den Nobelpreis gewonnen
wenn sie haben eben so entschlüssel
aufgenommen
genetischer Ebene wie das eigentlich
funktioniert mit diesem genetischen
Oszillator das war jetzt Ihnen das ein
bisschen kompliziert und auch nicht ganz
relevant für den Vortrag aber es zeigt
halt die Wichtigkeit die da eigentlich
schon erforscht wurde also das war
eigentlich ganz spannend genau jetzt
noch mal ein bisschen auf anatomische
Ebene wie funktioniert das also wir
hatten ja schon Licht ist es ist der
Zeitgeber der trifft auf die auf das
Auge dort wird es weiter verarbeitet
Signal ist auch relativ kompliziert
beschreibe ich jetzt nicht näher dann
geht es durch den optischen Nerv trifft
ins Gehirn wird dort verarbeitet im
suprakyasmatischen Nukleus das ist
unsere Masterclock nennen wir das auch
also quasi wie so ein Dirigent der dann
die ganzen unterschiedlichen Uhren in
unserem Körper steuert und
synchronisiert und wir wollen quasi dass
der Körper gut synchronisiert ist gut im
Einklang weil er dann am besten
funktionieren kann
und das hatte ich ja schon diese Uhren
gibt es eben in jedem Organ jeder Zelle
die dann eben wieder diese verschiedenen
Steuern hier haben wir mal ein paar
physiologische Rhythmen
dargestellt verschiedene
Ebenen also das kann sowohl Hormon Ebene
sein es kann auch Temperatur sein das
kann Zeitschätzung sein es kann tapping
sein tapping Verhalten oder auch Griff
gehabt also man sieht dass sie natürlich
zu verschiedenen Uhrzeiten
sich bewegen wo das tief und das hoch
ist aber im Endeffekt soll mit der Folie
einfach dargestellt werden das ist immer
ein Rhythmus gibt und das ist mit den
schwarzen das ist in der Nacht einfach
da gibt es den maximal gibt
genau ein wichtiges Modell in diesem
ganzen
in dieser ganzen Forschung das schon
sehr früh von bobbley also 1982
beschrieben wurde ist dieses to-process
Model jetzt versucht diese zwei Prozesse
des caardialen Prozesses also processy
und das schlafprozesses was ein
homöostatischer Prozess ist in Einklang
zu bringen denn und das ist jetzt das
komplizierte was auch dann in der
Umsetzung für die Hochschullehre
beispielsweise das alles für
komplizierter macht denn diese beiden
Prozesse sind immer in Interaktion das
heißt ich habe nicht nur einfach Maximum
und Minimum für irgendeine kognitiven
Prozess sondern das ist immer auch
beeinflusst von meinem vorherigen Schlaf
also wie lange habe ich geschlafen wann
habe ich geschlafen wie lange es bisher
und dadurch interakt interagieren diese
beiden Prozesse miteinander
man sieht jetzt hier auf der x-Achse
einfach eine gewisse Uhrzeit hier einmal
in Blau das schlaffenster schematisch
dargestellt und man sieht hier diesen
Rhythmus des kennen sie jetzt schon
immer nach oben noch ein unten und man
sieht hier aber auch dass ich quasi also
diese gerade Linie beschreibt jetzt den
Schlafdruck also das heißt im Endeffekt
die länger ich wach bin desto mehr
steigt der Druck zu schlafen das heißt
man sieht hier ist noch während danach
das heißt sie wurde noch abgebaut dann
steht die Person auf das jetzt nur eine
schematische Darstellung und dann je
länger man wach ist ist so eine Art
lineare lineare Anstieg
endlich das druckst und nur wenn der
Schlaf sehr hoch ist und der circa gerne
Prozess aber auch sagt hier jetzt werden
gute schlaffenster also an dieser Stelle
ist Schlaf dann quasi nach diesem Modell
auch möglich das heißt das beschreibt
auch so ein bisschen warum wir zum
Beispiel trotz Schlafmangel durch
Schichtarbeit am Tag nicht sonderlich
gut schlafen können nicht durchschlafen
andere schlafen
genau und uns tatsächlich so dass dieses
Modell einfach immer noch eines der
wichtigsten Modelle in der Chronologie
ist nach wie vorher es wird natürlich
viel mehr verfeinert noch angepasst
verkompliziert dadurch natürlich
passender für das echte Leben weil das
ist jetzt nur eine sehr vereinfachte
Darstellung genau innerhalb des Schlafes
das hatte ich jetzt schon ein bisschen
angesprochen gibt es auch Gutmensch das
nennt man dann ultra Diane Rhythmen weil
sie mehrmals am Tag passieren und in dem
Fall jetzt eben mehrmals innerhalb des
schlaffensters und sowas nennen wir dann
schlaf Architektur im ja also im
Fachbegriff man kennt aber auch unter
Schlaf Stadien die sich eben abwechseln
und schlaf sehr gut deswegen auch zügig
und zyklisch und sie kennen das
vielleicht dass wir quasi immer so circa
eineinhalb Stunden haben in der wir
durch verschiedene Schlafstadien wandern
das geht los mit dass wir wach sind
hier sind verschiedene eeg-muster also
elektroendzephalogramm Muster also
Gehirnströme die diese verschiedenen
Schlafstadien beschreiben sind hier
dargestellt und sie sehen also es gibt
zum Beispiel non RAM also nicht Rapid im
movement Schlaf ist es wird als N1 bis
n3-schlauch bezeichnet und dann gibt es
auch manchmal können sie auch das ist
der Schlaf wo die Augen hin und her
wandern und die letzten sich einfach ab
so dass wir in der im besten Fall oder
bzw in einem schematischen voll
eigentlich eher von N1 in den zwei in
den drei wandern in drei vier tiefste
Schlaf dann vielleicht wieder zurück zu
entzwei dann in die Rennphase
und so dauert es ungefähr 90 Minuten und
dann wechselt sich das wieder ab was sie
aber auch sehen ist dass der Tiefschlaf
also in drei hier häufiger am Anfang der
biologischen Nacht passiert und der
rennschlag eher gegen Ende
das hat eine gewisse Bedeutung das
merken das ist jetzt mal für später wenn
es um Schlafmangel geht denn wenn wir
jetzt hier künstlich irgendwas abkürzen
indem wir hier zum Beispiel mit dem
Wecker auf Wochen und einfach kürzlich
schlafen dann nehmen wir uns gewisse
Phasen die vorher nicht vorkommen im
Schlaf das muss man sich so ein bisschen
merken
weil eben die Rennphase häufiger gegen
Ende der Schlaf Episode stattfindet bei
den Untersuchungen im Andechser Bunker
ging es eben darum herauszufinden ob die
ob dieser interne Rhythmus denn
eigentlich jetzt intern ist oder ob wir
uns eigentlich nur Anpassen an die
Außenwelt also sprich ich kriege ein
Signal und dann passiert irgendwas im
Körper oder diese Rhythmus ist
eigentlich eh immer da und ich muss mich
mit meiner Außenwelt irgendwie
synchronisieren und deswegen hat immer
eben diese Bunker Experimente er sondern
um sich von allen möglichen äußeren
Einflüssen Einflüssen abzuschirmen wie
z.B eben auch Sonnenlicht damals wusste
immer wenn ich das Sonnenlicht der
Hauptzeit gebe ist und hat dann eben die
Teilnehmenden hier ich zeitlich ziemlich
lange also drei vier Wochen teilweise
sogar länger dort leben lassen und
einfach sich frei
bewegen lassen
und ähm
hier sieht man auch noch mal den Eingang
zu dem Punkt also wirklich total
abgeschirmt ist schon sehr spezielles
Experiment
und wir ziehen mal hier auch ganz schön
was dann letztendlich mit dem Rhythmus
passiert ist also wir sehen hier auf der
x-Achse die Ortszeit wieder das sind
jetzt hier mehrere Tage deswegen immer
12 24 12 24 also sprich mehreren Tage
sind hier hintereinander dargestellt und
auf der Y-Achse sehen Sie einfach die
Tage des Experiments also hier hat
einmal eine Person wirklich 30 Tage hier
in diesem Bunker verbracht
und was wir hier sehen ist sind so
aktivitätsrhythmen also Sonne ist immer
wann die Person Licht an hatte keine
Sonne weil es gab es nicht aber Licht an
und dunkel ist Licht aus
und diese Balken beschreiben man die
Person aktiv war in gestrichelt und
schwarz waren sie geschlafen hat das ist
jetzt der Anfang da wurde ganz gleich
immer zur selben Uhrzeit das Licht
angemacht und ausgemacht das war so um
die Person quasi erstmal zu
synchronisieren um den gleichen Rhythmus
zu haben ab Tag 5 oder so
123456 hat die Person sich selber
bestimmen können wann sie die Lichter
das Licht an und ausmacht und konnte
einfach leben mit zeitlich wie sie will
und was ist passiert der Rhythmus ist
völlig kollabiert es ist jetzt nicht
arithmisch weil das ist immer noch man
sieht schon dass es ein Rhythmus da ist
aber es verschiebt sich alles nach
rechts und das bedeutet im Endeffekt
dass die Person intern mehr als 24
Stunden hatte weil sie ja immer später
wird
jetzt ist es auch ein bisschen lustig
was da passiert ist denn es waren ja
wirklich Studierende die sich hier
gemeldet haben für für diese Experimente
und da gibt es eben ganz nette Anekdoten
aus dem Bunker weil viele haben sich da
vorbereitet für Abschlussprüfungen sonst
lese ich Ihnen das mal kurz vor ich
finde nämlich sehr sympathisch also die
Wissenschaftler nach der vereinbarten
Zeit die Türen des Bundes
protestierte der Student allerdings
liebhaft man habe ihn getäuscht der
abgesprochene Zeitraum sei ja noch gar
nicht zu Ende und er folglich mit seinen
Vorbereitungen noch längst nicht fertig
der Schlaf wach wird
Versuchsperson war völlig außer
Kontrolle geraten im Betrieb statt der
ca 24 Stunden fast 33 Stunden ohne dass
der Student sich dessen bewusst geworden
wäre wenn er glaubte ein Tagespensum in
rund 14 Stunden gearbeitet zu haben hat
er er in Wirklichkeit mehr als 20
Stunden daran gegessen
das Problem mit der Prüfungsvorbereitung
konnten die Andechser Wissenschaftler
lösen sie setzen sich mit dem prüfen in
Verbindung schilderten ihm die Situation
und vereinbarten einen neuen Termin also
sprich das war jetzt genau das was sie
gesehen haben in der Folie zuvor
statt den eben hier ca 24 Stunden ist es
einfach länger und dadurch verliert man
dann mit der Zeit weil wir einfach da 24
dann mehr als 400 Stunden
vorweisen es geht auch es gibt Sachen
die andere Richtung also dass dann der
interne Rhythmus geringer ist und diese
Variante ist völlig normale gesperrte
noch kurz darauf ein letztendlich ist es
so dass wir dieses Tageslicht brauchen
um diesen Rhythmus immer
an die Sonne quasi anzupassen dass sie
einfach mit unserer Umwelt
synchronisiert sind
genau jetzt habe ich ein bisschen über
die Uhr gesprochen wie hängt das jetzt
mit Schlaf und Schlafmangel zusammen
das ist jetzt genau das was ich meinte
also wir haben dieses Periode von 24
Stunden die variiert aber Person zu
Person und das kann eben bisschen kürzer
ein bisschen länger sein das ist ein
bisschen der Grund was wir verstehen
unter Eulen und nee ja das haben Sie
vielleicht gehört sehr früh Typen und
später Typen und das ist eine Idee
dahinter wie das zustande kommt dass es
eben Menschen gibt die ihr früh aktiv
sind da einfach besser performen im
Gegensatz zu anderen die eher spät am
Abend und ähm ja später am Abend gehen
arbeiten oder da auch besser sie
konzentrieren können beispielsweise
genau was die Anschluss den chronotyp
also hauptsächlich sind es schon
biologische Faktoren genetisch bedingt
die auch mit Geschlecht und Alter
variieren es hat auch was mit der
Lichtempfindlichkeit zu tun weil ich
habe ja schon erwähnt Sonne ist eben
wichtig für die Synchronisierung das
heißt was dann in meinem Auge passiert
ist auch relevant und das heißt es gibt
da auch genetische Variationen wie
lichtempfindlich ich bin und
entsprechend wie sich dann mein Körper
darauf anpassen kann man kann es
natürlich schon auch steuern indem wir
beispielsweise in der Kultur leben wo
schwer das Abendessen Aktivitäten am
Abend etc einfach stimulierend wirken
und so unseren Rhythmus beeinflussen und
genau also eben wie ich mich dem Licht
aussetzte also gibt's z.B in der Stadt
einfach eine gewisse Lichtverschmutzung
das heißt im Endeffekt zu viel Licht zu
lange im Vergleich zum eher ländlichen
Gebieten wo ich nicht so viel davon habe
ist es anders auch das Green verhalten
wie ein Fluss ist wenn wir zum Beispiel
spät abends Blaulicht viele konsumieren
also von Screens von lap top Handy und
so weiter dann hält mich das auch eher
wach genauso auch der Job bin ich viel
drin habe viel künstliches Licht habe
wenig intensives starkes Licht von außen
das dafür aber so die ganze Zeit danach
spät in die Nacht hinein dann ist mein
Rhythmus flacher insgesamt und nicht so
stark ausgeprägt was wiederum auch mein
Schlaf beeinflussen
genau das heißt man kann sich chronotyp
also auf einem Kontinuum vorstellen und
man kann da schon ein bisschen hin und
her wandern zwischen ein bisschen
frühtyp bisschen Spättyp aber man kann
dann nie den komplett ändern also man
wird jetzt nicht von dem kompletten
sperrtyp auf einmal irgendwann ein
frühtyp das lässt sich nicht
antrainieren oder so man kann es ein
Verhalten ändern aber man kann dann
nicht die Biologie dahinter ändern das
heißt im Endeffekt ist es dann immer
masking bezahlen das als masking weil
man das quasi einfach überschreibt von
außen aber im Endeffekt ändert sich
biologisch jetzt nicht genau und das ist
jetzt spannend irgendwann für die
Hochschullehre weil wir sehen hier dass
es ähm dass diese später
sich nämlich und unterscheiden vom Alter
und vom Geschlecht ist hatte ich kurz
erwähnen und man sieht man sieht hier
zwei Kurven einmal die ähm die Frauen
und einmal die Männer und hier auf der
X-Achse ist einfach das Alter abgetragen
Uhrzeit das heißt die später die Uhrzeit
desto später ist der Grundtyp auch und
wir sehen hier einfach extrem
markante Verspätung während der
Jugendzeit die dann so mit anfangen 20
bei bei Männern auch ein bisschen später
erst sich wieder wendet und man dann im
Laufe seines Lebens wieder so ein
bisschen früher wird und das heißt diese
Phase während der Jugendzeit um Gegner
während der jungen erwachsenenzahl das
extrem wichtig weil wir dort eben diesen
diese Rhythmus Verspätung sehen was
letztendlich natürlich auch mit dem
Lernfenster dann in Zusammenhang steht
also wann die Personen gut lernen können
jetzt ist das nächste das Teenager aber
auch noch mehr Schlaf brauchen als
Erwachsene so sie sind also nicht nur
später sondern sie schlafen auch noch
später länger Entschuldigung also wenn
wir jetzt hier zum Beispiel einen
Lehrenden haben der braucht vielleicht
acht Stunden Schlaf das ist jetzt auch
nur ein Durchschnitt wieder von uns
macht unterschiedliche Mengen an Schlaf
aber nehmen wir mal acht Stunden an und
der schläft von zehn bis sechs Uhr
morgens
dann ist es ein solides Fenster von 8
Stunden die Jugendlichen und jungen
Erwachsenen gehen später ins Bett
schlafen später müssen aber vielleicht
zur selben Uhrzeit Aufstehen gerade in
der Schule und schneiden damit ihren
Schlaf künstlich ab die brauchen aber
mehr als wir die Teenager die brauchen
ca 8 bis 10 Stunden das sehen wir auch
immer noch bei jungen Erwachsenen die
meinetwegen in den ersten Semestern
studieren das heißt im Endeffekt haben
die immer an den konstanten Schlafmangel
was sie dann ausgleichen am Wochenende
und da gibt es ein paar so Befragungen
auch wo befragt wurde wie müde die
Jugendlichen eigentlich in der Schule
und ergeben 33 Prozent
im Unterricht war Einschlafen also ein
Drittel schläft ein es ist dann schon
recht viel
doch durch als optimieren lassen würde
genau das Problem ist aber auch dass die
Adoleszenz und sicher auch noch bis
Mitte der 20er Jahre viele Veränderungen
mit sich bringt weil die Reifen und
Vernetzung innerhalb des
sehr sehr wichtig ist für logisches
Denken für
komplizierte Zusammenhänge herstellen
und so weiter einfach bis Mitte 20 noch
weitergeht also das ist jetzt nicht mit
18 vorbei das heißt das betrifft schon
auch unsere ersten Semester späteren
Semester sogar auch noch ein bisschen
dass die davon betroffen sind dass sich
da einfach Reifungsprozesse im Gehirn
abspielen das heißt wir haben einfach
diese gehirnreifung und auch körperliche
Veränderungen die alle damit die ideale
wenn der alle deszenz und dann auch noch
wichtig sind und entstehen und davon
betroffen sind genauso auch
Skelettwachstum etc und das alles aber
oder vieles davon passiert halt auch im
Schlaf
und das heißt es ist einfach extrem
wichtig dass wir
das hier ausreichend schlafen und
gesunden Schlaf haben damit das alles
gut funktionieren kann
jetzt wissen wir auch das Schlafmangel
eben sowohl akut als auch chronisch
nicht so toll ist und akut vielleicht
noch okay also wobei das auch schon ein
bisschen schwierig ist wenn wir zum
Beispiel akut sehr großen Schlafmangel
haben und dann Auto fahren und zum
Beispiel Unfälle produzieren da komme
ich gleich noch dazu es ist aber
insgesamt länger gesehen auch schlecht
zum Beispiel für
schlechtere Immunfunktion reduzierte
physische Leistungsfähigkeit etc alles
was Sie hier sehen sprich es ist einfach
ungesund wenn wir dauerhaft zu wenig
schlafen
und wir bezahlen das dann auch als
sozialen Jetlag wenn wir unter der Woche
zum Beispiel eben immer unseren Schlaf
verkürzen müssen durch
schulanfangszeiten oder Schule oder so
und wir dann am Wochenende diesen Schlaf
versuchen nachzuholen indem er
ausschlafen dann haben wir quasi wenn
Sie die Schlafmütze nehmen
einen shift zwischen Wochenende und
Arbeitstagen oder Verein und
Arbeitstagen und das nennen wir dann
auch sozialen Jetlag was so ein bisschen
ist wie wenn wir zum Beispiel nach
Amerika fliegt und seine innere Uhr sich
dann erstmal an die neue Zeitzone
anpassen muss
und auch dieser soziale Jetlag hängt wie
chronische Schlafmangel auch mit
schlechteren Gesundheit
reliktionen zusammen sprich es erhöht
zum Beispiel Diabetes und Dickleibigkeit
rauchen und Drogen bzw Alkoholkonsum
steht damit irgendwie in Verbindung und
Risiko steigt
genau es liegt sprich insgesamt wird es
schon zumindest innerhalb unseren Fällen
unseres Feldes diskutiert dass das der
Schlafmangel schon auch ein gewisses
Hochrisiko Verhalten eigentlich
darstellt was in der Gesellschaft nicht
so ganz erkannt wird ich liste jetzt
hier einfach ein paar Sachen auf die bin
ich sehr erschreckend sind also
Schlafmangel ist zum Beispiel
vergleichbar mit kognitiven
Einschränkungen verursacht durch
mittleren Alkoholkonsum dann gibt es
auch sowas wie es wird eher oft vermutet
man kann sich da schon anpassen also
Nachtschichten zum Beispiel Ärzte die
oder Ärztinnen die an Nachtschichten
Gebühren sind die die können sich dann
schon irgendwann mal anpassen das stimmt
nicht man kann sich dann nicht
biologisch dran anpassen man kann da
sich dran gewöhnen vielleicht aber eben
die schon erwähnt haben nicht biologisch
anpassen dann gibt's eben viele Unfälle
die auch durch Übermüdung verursacht
sind immer eigentlich vermeiden hätte
können ähm auch gibt's mir Arbeits- und
Verkehrsunfälle in diesen ganzen Schicht
und Nacharbeit tatsächlich ist auch
Übermüdung einer der bekanntesten
vermeidbaren Gründe für den
Transportwesen ist höher die Rat der
Arzt sich Alkohol und Drogen beeinflusst
die Unfälle und jetzt sehen wir hier
auch eine Einfluss wieder also nicht nur
der Schlafmangel sondern wir den circa
die Einfluss das eben viele Unfälle
zwischen es in der Nacht Zeit passieren
zwischen 0 und 6 Uhr und auch in diesen
Mittagstief
genau letztendlich ist es einfach auch
mit einer gewissen erhöhten Mortalität
assoziiert und langer Schlaf an
Wochenende kann es aber an so ein
bisschen ausgleichen
genau wir sehen es auch also
hochrisikoverhalten und tatsächlich
eines der größten Probleme moderne
Gesellschaften das Gute daran ist man
kann es ja aber eigentlich schon auch
beheben jetzt haben wir uns noch kurz an
wie sie denn eigentlich deutsche
Jugendliche so schlafen Vergleich zu
Erwachsenen zum Beispiel da haben wir
einen einen Fragebogen der ist der heißt
Unicorn damit kann man den chronotyp
eben erheben und da schauen wir uns
jetzt Daten an von deutschen
Jugendlichen im Vergleich im Alter von
14 bis 19 im Vergleich zu 30 bis
50-Jährige dann haben wir hier eine
relativ große Stichprobe und das sehen
Sie hier ähm blau die Jugendlichen in
grau die aber Erwachsenen das ist
einfach die Anzahl der Personen und hier
ist auf der x-Achse wie lange die
Personen schlafen an Schul bzw
Arbeitstagen da ist es so ein bisschen
gleich wobei die jungen Erwachsenen oder
Jugendlichen ein bisschen
mehr schlafen
am Wochenende schaut man schon anders
aus und wir glauben eben dass das
schlaffenster am Wochenende so ein
bisschen eher das biologisch relevante
ist
wobei es auch vermengt ist mit dem mit
dem Schlafmangel und dann ziehen wir
hier auch den sozialen Jetlag also ist
klar je mehr Stunden Jetlag desto
schlechter das ganze das heißt hier
haben auch die Jugendlichen und jungen
Erwachsenen einfach mehr sozialen Jetlag
genau also kurzes zwischen Fazit
Jugendliche und junge erwachsen sind im
Durchschnitt chronisch sind auch im
Durchschnitt spätere chronotypen und
lernen somit eigentlich auch späterer
besser und das ganze passiert eigentlich
bis mitte ende 20er Jahre
so what also was machen wir jetzt mit
diesem ganzen Wissen für die
Hochschullehre oder Lehrer insgesamt
genau also jetzt nehme ich sie noch mal
kurz mit auf die 24 Stunden hier das ist
jetzt alles nicht so in Stein gemeißelt
also machen Sie jetzt keinen Screenshot
von den Uhrzeiten und sagen Sie ah ja um
10 Uhr ist die beste die beste
Aufmerksamkeit da muss ich jetzt alles
machen nein das ist natürlich jetzt
nicht so ein Stein gemeißelt aber man
sieht halt gewisse Variante Variationen
innerhalb zum Beispiel der
Aufmerksamkeit da gehe ich gleich noch
drauf ein waren zum Beispiel ich am
besten ja Koordination zeige wann ich
meine Reaktionsfähigkeit vielleicht
schneller ist und so weiter und so fort
das Ganze spielt vor allem zum Beispiel
haben Spitzensport der große Rolle
hat aber natürlich auch für uns eine
Relevanz also Aufmerksamkeit ist eher
erhöht am späten Vormittag während so
allgemeine physische Performens eher am
späten Nachmittag am besten funktioniert
und das muss man sich auch so ein
bisschen merken optimale physische
Leistung korreliert meistens auch
irgendwie mit der maximalen
körperkenntemperatur die sich ja auch
verändert ungefähr um ein halbes Grad
innerhalb der 24 Stunden
eben wichtig ist aber jetzt dass sie das
jetzt nicht an gewissen Uhrzeiten
festmachen weil das ist alles Biologie
das heißt es variiert alles das variiert
auch mit dem chronotyp und für sich
selber kann man einfach schauen das man
fährt eigentlich am besten wenn man auf
den eigenen Körper achtet und sich klar
macht wie Tick ich eigentlich und sich
das so ein bisschen selber gut
kennenlernt
jetzt wollte ich noch mal kurz den Blick
auf die Aufmerksamkeit lenken weil die
natürlich wichtig ist für das Lernen
insgesamt und jetzt gehen wir mal von
einer Person aus die von 23 bis 7 Uhr
schläft und so mittlerer chronotyp ist
dann wäre jetzt zum Beispiel wenn man
das wirklich eine Uhrzeiten festmachen
würde eher so eine geringe
Aufmerksamkeit am Morgen zwischen sieben
und zehn dann mehr verbesserte
Aufmerksamkeit zwischen 10 und 14 Uhr
ungefähr dann gibt's diesen typischen
Post
sie alle zwischen also nachher
Mittagessen vielleicht zwischen 14 und
16 Uhr der
hauptsächlich zur tatjan ist aber auch
was damit zu tun hat wie viele ich esse
also man kann ihn auch verringern diesen
Effekt indem ich einfach nicht so stark
und viel esse
am Nachmittag wird dann die
Aufmerksamkeit noch mal viel besser und
so am Abend nimmt es dann rapide ab in
der Nacht ganz schlecht und am Morgen
ist es dann am schlechtesten und jetzt
will ich hier nur mit dieser Grafik hier
links noch mal darstellen was das Ganze
so problematisch macht das irgendwie
in
handfeste Empfehlungen zu verpacken ist
ganz einfach dass das ist einfach so
viele verschiedene Prozesse gibt die
hier die ich mir hier anschauen kann
also allein da Aufmerksamkeit wo man
denkt naja Aufmerksamkeit das ist ein
kognitiver Prozess ist der kann jetzt
nicht so schwierig sein da irgendwie
eine feste Uhrzeit dafür festzumachen
war nicht lernen soll es gibt aber auch
verschiedene Arten von Aufmerksamkeit es
gibt jetzt hier zum Beispiel Tonic
Erlebnis
und das sind alles Unterarten von
Aufmerksamkeit dann gibt es unter Arten
von verschiedenen körperlichen
Leistungsfähigkeiten und so weiter und
so fort und sie merken schon jetzt wird
das alles einfach viel komplizierter als
man sich vielleicht nicht
denkt und somit auch schwerer das an
ganz ganz festen Uhrzeiten
weil wir werden oft gefragt ja wann soll
ich dann zum Beispiel Mathematik in der
Schule unterrichten und das ist
natürlich so ein bisschen schwierig
das heißt aber trotzdem kann man schon
davon wie bisher Konsequenzen ziehen und
so ist es so dass wir einfach für
Lernende aber auch für uns lernen
einfach optimale Lern- und
lehrzeiträume gibt für verschiedenste
also zum Beispiel Sport vielleicht nicht
gleich um 8 Uhr morgens
auch kreatives muss jetzt nicht
unbedingt werden Schlafmangel passieren
weil da ist man das meistens nicht so
dann gibt es einfach auf Prüfungszeit
Räume die man gestorben könnte und es
gibt halt Aktivitäten die mehr oder
weniger von Schlafmangel getroffen sind
sprich ich kann jetzt am Morgen schon
eher leichten Sport machen der ist sehr
rhythmisch ist also spricht zum Beispiel
wandern
doch eher gehen als ich zum Beispiel
irgendwie eine neue
Unterrichtseinheit zu komplexen Zahlen
das wird für einige dann doch um 8 Uhr
morgens gerne Herausforderung genau
haben hier also zwei Kolleginnen und ich
haben hier für die belgische Regierung
für die für den deutschsprachigen Teil
in Belgien ein Gutachten erstellt wie
man sowas in der Sekundarschule
vielleicht
umsetzen könnte also wenn Sie sich
interessieren dafür dann können Sie es
gerne scannen dazu es führt sie zu dem
Dokument ist auf deutsch der ausführlich
zum Thema ja Unterrichtszeiten in der in
der Sekundarstufe hauptsächlich und
haben wir hier verschiedene Felder
abgedeckt einmal was die Einzelperson
selber machen kann bzw man in der
Verhaltensebene ansetzen kann
Entschuldigung in der Verhältnis
verhältnissebene und dann gibt es
natürlich auch Sachen auf der
Verhaltensebene was man als einzelne
Person noch machen kann insgesamt also
alles was so ein bisschen umrand ist
hier da gibt es mehr Evidenz dazu und
deswegen würden wir das jetzt auch eher
vorschlagen
dass man gerade in der Sekundarstufe
verschiedene
schulanfangszeiten mal bedenkt also die
eher zu verspäten dann wäre es auch
wichtig und das ist auch relevant für
die Hochschullehre dass man irgendwie
mehr Tageslicht schafft und auch die
Innenräume heller mit mehr blau reichen
Licht macht also sprich die Beleuchtung
spielt da auch eine große Rolle was die
Aufmerksamkeit aber auch die für den
Rhythmus einfach wichtig ist dann gibt
es auch saisonale Veränderungen
natürlich die man bedenken könnte und
einfach tagesrhythmik bei der
Stundenplan Gestaltung das ist jetzt
natürlich für die Sekunden schon noch
mal viel relevanter weil das alles sehr
viel mehr getaktet ist als in der
Hochschullehre trotzdem könnte man sich
da schon überlegen ob es da
Möglichkeiten gibt
auf individual Ebene kann man natürlich
immer was anbieten was
Gesundheitskompetenz betrifft dass man
sich da einfach mehr auskennt mehr
lernen darüber was das eigentlich Schlaf
bedeutet was Rhythmus bedeutet und mir
das vielleicht auch wichtig ist dass ich
das wie ein Gesundheitsverhalten auch da
mit bedenken
genau also Lösungsideen die sich
vielleicht dann auch für die
Hochschullehre eignen man könnte eben
ich weiß dass das alles nicht einfach
umzusetzen um das geht jetzt hier auch
gerade nicht sondern eher so was was
gibt es denn für Ideen die mit normal
Bedenken könnte also man könnte die
Zeitplanung noch flexibler machen sie
ist ja relativ in der Hochschullehre für
den Studierenden zumindest eher einfach
inzwischen jetzt auch mit dem
Hintergrund der hybriden Veranstaltungen
das heißt man muss jetzt nicht direkt um
8 Uhr reinkommen und sich gleich nicht
vorlesen setzen wenn man jetzt nicht der
früh-typ ist weil vieles jetzt
aufgezeichnet wird man kann sich das zu
einer späteren Zeitpunkt auch anschauen
trotzdem werden natürlich die Überlegung
muss ich jetzt eigentlich überhaupt um 8
Uhr noch irgendwelche Vorlesungen zum
Beispiel machen
auch Prüfungs das vielleicht relevant
der Prüfungen müsste ich vielleicht
nicht um 8 Uhr stattfinden lassen also
es ist eigentlich auch unfair es gibt da
viele
Untersuchungen dazu dass die
unterschiedlichen kronotypen da
unterschiedlich abschneiden je nachdem
wann die Prüfung stattfindet da bin ich
jetzt gar nicht drauf eingegangen aber
spätere chronotypen haben eigentlich
immer im Durchschnitt schlechtere Noten
ähm einfach weil sie auch zu
schlechteren Seiten geprüft werden das
könnte mal hier anpassen und man kann
sich natürlich überlegen muss ich jetzt
Mathe um 8 Uhr unterrichten kann ich das
auch später machen oder eben das die
verschiedenen Unterrichtsfächer an den
Tageszeitpunkt anpassen und natürlich
und das passiert zum Beispiel an der TUM
auch im Rahmen von Gesundheit
Aufklärungskampagnen könnte man auch die
Schlafhygiene damit reinbringen
schlafgesundheit circa gerne Gesundheit
um da einfach die Studierenden auch noch
mal mit abzuholen
was ich noch ganz spannend fand das
wollte ich ihnen nur noch mitgeben dass
die Chronobiologie eben sehr ein
Grundlagen Forschungsfeldes man das aber
wie sie jetzt sehr sehen auch stark
anwenden kann und da gibt es eben
verschiedene Bereiche einmal kann man
eben die Madison im Bereich der
Prävention Coaching Behandlung oder
Aufklärung
hier wirken lassen genauso wird es auch
viel im Arbeitsschutz und
Arbeitssicherheit noch mal angewand also
zum Beispiel werden kann man Unternehmer
geraten über die verschiedenen
Schichtsysteme auch darüber aufklären
was eigentlich Langzeitfolgen von
Schicht dabei sind und ein ganz
spannendes und ihr neueres Thema ist die
chronopharmakologie nämlich wie sich
Medikamente
wie die Steigerung von der Wirksamkeit
von Medikamenten eigentlich möglich wäre
oder auch die Reduzierung von
Nebenwirkungen an dem man einfach die
Medikamentengabe an den chronotyp
beispielsweise anpasst und somit auch
geringere Toxizität
von den Medikamenten erreicht also sehr
sehr spannend mit gerade in der
krebsforschungsjahr hochgehalten und
erforscht und also den ist hat alles
nicht nur was mit der Hochschullehre zu
tun sondern kann man aber viele andere
Bereiche anwenden und ja ich hoffe das
hat jetzt ein bisschen mitgenommen und
zusammenfassen will ich einfach noch mal
sagen dass die innere Uhr überall in
unserem Körper steckt und sich mit der
Außenwelt synchronisiert der Schlaf
selber auch gewisseurinnen hat die wir
eben nicht beeinflussen können oder nur
sehr marginal
ich glaube das wissen wir alle der
Schlaf wichtig ist für unser psychisches
und physisches Wohlergehen und ich
glaube ich habe jetzt auch gesagt dass
besonders die Jugendlichen und junge
Erwachsenen sehr unter Schlafmangel
leiden und ja das Argument kommt immer
natürlich machen die auch Dinge wie viel
am Handy Datteln und viel wach bleiben
und Gaming und sonst was was das
verschlechtert aber wir sehen es auch in
vielen vielen anderen Kulturen wusste
alles nicht gibt
dass die Jugendlichen und das sieht man
sogar bei Tieren in der adeleszenz
einfach einen verspäteten Rhythmus
zeigen das heißt da kommen einfach
verschiedene Faktoren zusammen die das
dann einfach noch mal verstärken
das heißt man könnte eben Leere und
prüfungszeiträume ein bisschen an diesen
Rhythmus anpassen und wir wissen eben
dass der Schlaf ausreichend sein muss
und gesund um die lehrleistung auch zu
fördern damit bin ich am Ende ich
bedanke mich sehr sehr herzlich für die
Einladung und für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
und auch dass sie hier mit meinen
schlechten Internet bei mir geblieben
sind vielen Dank dafür und jetzt kommen
wir hoffentlich noch hoffentlich noch
kurz diskutieren